بالنسبة لملايين المسلمين من البلدان السبعة
التي يُطلق عليها حظر المسلمين الذين منعهم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من دخول الولايات المتحدة ،
فإن إلغاء الرئيس جو بايدن أمر
مرحب به للغاية ولكن لعشرات الآلاف من
اللاجئين من تلك البلدان الذين
يأملون في إعادة التوطين في الولايات المتحدة.
قد يكون الإلغاء هو
الفرق بين الحياة أو الموت
هنا في كينيا وحدها منذ حوالي ثلاث
سنوات عندما دخل الحظر حيز التنفيذ لأول مرة ،
كان هناك
حوالي 26000 لاجئ صومالي
كانوا ينتظرون
سنوات لإعادة التوطين في الولايات المتحدة في الواقع ،
تم إخبار نصفهم بالفعل
أنه تمت الموافقة على إعادة توطين
بعضهم في ذلك الوقت ،
وصفوا لنا أنه تم إيقاف الرحلات الجوية
التي اعتقدوا أنها تنقلهم إلى
منازل جديدة وحياة جديدة في الولايات المتحدة الآن
مع هذا الإلغاء ، يقول الكثيرون
إنهم يشعرون أخيرًا
أنه يمكنهم الأمل مرة أخرى  أنه يمكنهم
أن يحلموا مرة أخرى
بحياة حياة جديدة في الولايات المتحدة